If you enjoy wine and like golf, a visit to the Okanagan Valley...
...in Canada's British Columbia would gratify both.
The valley with its 128-kilometer-long Okanagan Lake...
...is a flourishing fruit growing area...
...and renowned for its up-and-coming wine industry.
The town of Kelowna is a good starting point...
...and a great place to appreciate...
...the sandy lake beachfront and busy restaurant scene.
There are more than 100 wineries to choose from.
The Mission Hill Winery is among the most famous.
Apart from a number of contests as part of their promotions program,...
...they also have a concert series in their outdoor amphitheater,...
...as well as culinary workshops.
Two of the most prestigious golf courses in B.C. are The Quail,...
...built in 1994 by the famous golf course architect Les Furber and The Bear.
You are assured of dramatic elevation changes, large multi-tiered fairways,...
...and breathtaking views of magnificent ponderosa pine forests.